evergrand is a huge story out of china
that a lot of people aren't talking
about yet evergrande is uh one of the
most important assets in the chinese
economy and it looks like it is
imploding before our eyes you could say
that the headline here is evergrand
screwed a bunch of people in china
literally
after expanding very rapidly for years
this company
has been snapping up assets in the
chinese economy the evergrand business
is now
suffering under an absolute immense
amount of debt about 300 billion dollars
worth of debt and so let's start with
what is evergreen this china evergrand
business they own about 1300 1 300 real
estate projects in over 280 cities in
china
its property service management arm is
involved in nearly 2 800 projects across
more than 310 cities in china so they
own a bunch of real estate projects and
they also have a property management arm
for a bunch of projects as well the
company has seven units dabbling in a
wide range of industries including
eclectic vehicle or electric vehicles
healthcare services consumer products
video and television production units
and even a theme park
they say that they have over 200 000
employees but indirectly more than 3.8
million
jobs every year
great research by our outsourced partner
bloomberg
evergreen
was the country's largest high-yield
dollar bond issuer
the largest issuer
16
of all outstanding notes in china came
from this one company
and now that
they have been forced because of the
structural issues
to delay payments on up to 40 billion
won
in wealth management products
there are now protests across the
country where all these people are
coming and saying hey i rely on you for
income i rely on you because you have a
material percent of my portfolio
give me my money back give me my yield
payment and the company is saying we
can't do that right now very very big
story and so we've got two quotes here
the first comes from mark williams the
chief asia economist at capital
economics said evergrand's collapse
would be the biggest test that china's
financial system has faced in years
and then we've got dan wang
from the economist
or the economist at hong seng bank
evergrand is such an important real
estate developer and it would be a
strong signal if anything happened to it
i believe there will be some supporting
measures from the central government or
even the central bank trying to bail out
evergrand now as we know in 2008 2009
the us government determined some
financial institutions to be too big to
fail
and they stepped in and they saved them
they propped them up they prevented
collapse of the system
probably was a pretty good decision
but a lot of people were unhappy about
the way that it occurred
and so when you think about this the
chinese economy is massive the chinese
financial system is massive
this is
their equivalent
one of if not the largest player
with over 300 billion dollars of debt
is in trouble
and we don't yet know is the government
or the central bank gonna step in and
determine them too big to fail
investors though
ain't very happy we've got the stock
price here as you can imagine it's going
down
it's probably not going down nearly as
fast as you would think it was going
down
but the year-to-date move is significant
it's lost over 60
of its value and it looks like it's
headed to zero
now if the government steps in and saves
it it won't go to zero the government
doesn't step in and save it it won't go
to zero now the shareholder wipeout
evergrand stock is down 90
from the 2020 high
and as you can see here the
hang sen china enterprises index
is essentially flat slightly down
but the evergrand stock has fallen off a
clip a cliff
and then if you go and you look at the
actual outstanding debt by type
this is from december 31st 2020 you can
see that the secured bank and other
borrowings make up about half of all
outstanding debt the unsecured bank and
other borrowings is about 17
then they have the prc bond six percent
the senior nodes are 21
and convertible bonds are 2
absolute bonkers numbers when you start
to look at these charts and see 54 of
the debt is secured bank and other
borrowings unsecured 17
and then lastly
again
great
work by bloomberg here looking at the
bloomberg billionaire index
the pin duo duo founder
colin huang
has lost
the most money in the world this year
world record
i would clap it that's bad yeah i don't
want to celebrate somebody being uh hurt
here i put this on here because of the
um of hai
kai
wang
which one don't even yeah just let it go
fourth one the fourth one on the list
there is uh he's the chairman of the
evergrand group and he's lost about
looks like 15 billion or so but colin
hwang from pin duo duo has lost almost
30 billion 25 30 billion and this data
is uh september 15th so it's only two
days old at this point so i mean we'll
see if the stock keeps going down though
he may rise the ranks on that chart i
mean
a lot of people want to be a lot of
people want to be at the top of uh of a
list
being at the top of the biggest drops in
net worth globally not the list you want
to be at the top of all five of these
folks though
are involved here uh from my
understanding
and uh
if you think about
how catastrophic this is
you have individuals that are losing 25
billion
of their personal net worth
the chairman 15 billion
i mean right there's 40 billion right
you just start to kind of add this stuff
up and
i don't know this for a fact but my
guess
is that the
individuals that were holding lots of
this debt or a lot of equity in this
business thought it was the safe part of
their investment a portfolio they didn't
think that it was uh you know the risky
part the asymmetric part they thought
that this was a much
lower risk
investment opportunity that they
actually were engaging biggest bond
issuer in china so 16 we think that the
is the government or the central bank
gonna step in right like there's there's
uh banks obviously there's homeowners uh
investors individuals etc uh employees
obviously i think you said earlier they
have like two or three million employees
every year that they they uh send out
for work like the government or the
central bank has to step in at some
point right it's almost too big to fail
uh within the chinese market i would
expect that is that is essentially the
argument that a lot of people are making
is like look this company and even
before the crash of it was like it's too
big to fail no matter what happens it
will not fail um but now that we're
seeing it kind of tank it's it's
interesting to make that argument of
will someone step in and basically help
them right we saw a lot of that even
happening on uh in the u.s of the
airlines got in trouble people stepped
in they helped um like the government
stepped in and helped so we'll we'll see
i i don't know the answer well uh here
in the u.s the government likes to make
deals that private uh private investors
wouldn't make so we'll see if the
chinese government does the same thing
that's bait i'm not gonna take it
it's true though i mean
i can't call up the
treasury secretary like warren buffett
did and strike a backroom deal but hey
whatever um
two bigger questions
do we think that this has anything to do
with china and their relationship to
billionaires in general and how they
have been uh
encouraging the billionaires maybe not
to be as powerful or as involved in
businesses in the past could that could
that be some sort of uh this isn't a
surprise this actually could be some
sort of uh structural
well like that the the company's failing
in the stock market so jack ma you know
yeah yeah jack
vacation yeah he's on vacation
uh
is there any of that going on here as
well he just happens to look like he
wants to take you know videos on
vacation that he's in a hostage
situation but
we'll leave that for a different day
i mean that's what let's just have let's
just call spay to spay that's what
happened
right the guy the guy the guy had
literally i am okay
guys i think i had to present a
proof-of-life video like the internet
was like where's jack ma i wasn't seeing
them
they were like uh
i am okay no problem
right um and so when you when you think
about uh
the amount of wealth that's been lost
here is pretty it's pretty crazy on top
of that though
the
largest bond issuer
losing so much market share and power
like this
you got to think that you got at least
asked the question right is there
anything involved with that and then the
second piece of it is
if it becomes weaker
and the government steps in in the
united states we're real chill about
this stuff right we basically were like
ah we'll give you some cash we'll save
you we got you yeah airlines like just
keep the money for free like literally
we don't want any equity we don't get
any interest on majority of the cash
like just like we're idiot investors
like you and you think he's gonna like
he's gonna have like he's gonna owe the
government basically or some kind forget
that i think governor's gonna say we own
this business now no yeah i mean like
something like this like not like i owe
you cash like not like i am the captain
now yeah like i am the business now like
like i get out of my office like yeah
like this is my office now by the way
you i don't even know your name security
remove him yeah i am the president now i
am the ceo now and so
if that occurs maybe nothing changes
maybe they can get right back on track
and everything is fine it just gets
nationalized whatever uh
but i cannot the
essentially planned economy
that is so so so concerned with having a
stable financial system because if you
have a stable financial system in a
communist uh regime
it keeps the peace
everyone has just enough of what they
need so that there isn't um uh the
people don't rise up and and uh and
fight back
i don't think that there's a world where
china can let this fail
right like there's too much strategic
importance for stability
china does not want people protesting in
the street they do not want there was
videos that i saw of people literally at
the offices chanting give me my money
yeah it's not that's not uh that's not
cool
over there what i went down like a
rabbit hole of uh some some serious
stuff with this company people tell us
more
people were apparently like trying to
find like managers and executives in the
company and like like take them
like kidnap them yeah
what sites were you on
this was just like on craigslist there
was an ad
courtesy of uh
there was a few but one was uh zero
hedge so you know those guys are a
little out there anyways yeah and what
were they saying they were saying that
people were trying to find the
executives yeah
i'll find the article i'll put in the
chat i mean look by the way that doesn't
surprise me yeah right i mean
if you're somebody who has put your
assets in what you deem to be a low-risk
security and then it ends up being risky
probably not good hey guys bang bang
thanks so much for watching the best
business show today and don't forget to
check out our partner sofi they make all
this possible they're a super app that
lets you save spend borrow earn and
invest all from one single platform and
if you go there today and you sign up
for a sofi invest account you can get
between five dollars and a thousand
bucks for free from sofa not everyone's
obviously gonna get a thousand dollars
but everyone gets something don't say
that i never did anything for you go
check them out at sofi.compomp
download the app and go ahead and open
an account sofi.compomp
and make sure you come back and watch
more of the best business show we're
going to build the biggest business show
in the world and we need your help
[Music]